president trump plans to return to the
campaign trail today in florida
following a political event at the white
house
on saturday where he spoke from a
balcony he spent the weekend
claiming he's tested negative and that
he's now immune from the coronavirus
even though neither
assertion has been confirmed by his
doctors
he's also now in a new dispute with dr
anthony fauci
ben tracy reports on the latest
confusion from the white house
over the president's health
president trump made more claims about
his health over the weekend including on
a call to support her sunday
i've been tested totally negative i'm
going to be out in florida tomorrow
working very hard
because this is an election we have to
win but neither the white house nor the
president's doctors have confirmed the
president has in fact tested negative
for kovit
the word immunity means something having
having really a protective glow
earlier in the day the president said
he's not only beaten the virus
but claims he's also now immune it looks
like i'm immune for
i don't know maybe a long time and maybe
a short time it could be a lifetime
nobody really knows but i'm immune so
so the president is in very good shape
but it's not yet known if people who
recover from the virus are actually
immune or for how long
when the president tweeted sunday saying
he can't get or give the virus
twitter flagged his tweet for spreading
misleading and potentially harmful
information about coven 19.
president trump's physician dr sean
conley released this memo saturday night
saying the president is no longer
considered a transmission risk to others
and there is no longer evidence of
actively replicating virus
that was the president's ticket to
resume campaigning as
polls in several key states show he is
trailing former vice president joe biden
president trump tackled the virus
head-on the trump campaign is being
criticized
for a new ad in which dr anthony fauci
seems to be endorsing the president's
handling of the virus
i can't imagine that anybody could be
doing more
in a statement sunday fauci said the
comments attributed to me without my
permission in the gop campaign ad
were taken out of context and i have
never publicly endorsed
any political candidate president trump
tweeted that these are fouchy's own
words
praising the administration's response
but in the march interview fauci was
actually talking about the white house
coronavirus task force
he never mentioned president trump
president trump and former vice
president joe biden were supposed to be
meeting this thursday for the second
presidential debate but that debate was
canceled by
the debate commission for health reasons
after president trump refused to do it
virtually
both candidates now plan to do their own
separate town halls
on that night gail all right ben thank
you very much